And let's welcome everybody to another webinar.
This is Dr. Cameron Cutters.
This is not so radical cancer diet,
but really on any questions that you might have
regarding any, I think particularly cancer,
but regarding anything.
We have some questions that we had asked before
this all started,
but please check your questions in.
We'll stay as long as I can
and get as many questions as we can answered.
Question that came in,
hi, my daughter is, was been diagnosed with uingsarcoma.
And we just had news after surgeries
and very strong radiation
that she's got more nodules
and they want to do chemo.
Is there anything you could do from a natural perspective?
So uingsarcoma is probably less related to diet,
but I get any questions or welcome.
So uingsarcoma is typically found
in the distal leg of young people in the sarcoma
that is typically fairly nasty.
They used to just do surgery and remove the leg.
Now they're doing chemo therapy
and some other radiation therapies with it.
But definitely using rife technology,
which is frequency technology,
which if you followed me for very long, you know that.
I'm pretty pro on that
and then dealing with some immune stimulation.
So you've got to get that person's immune system
fighting that cancer.
And you could definitely prolong that person's life
and give them better results.
I'll try to get to the questions
that you guys chat in first.
So I'm going to have to be taking my glasses on and off
because I don't have my focus.
Any suggestions for none?
Melanoma skin cancers.
So there's really three main skin cancers
that we're talking about is basal cell
and squabous cell and melanoma.
So squabous cell and basal cell
would be the none, primary none melanoma skin cancers.
Basal cell is very fairly identifiable.
People get it on their face as they get older.
It looks like a little shiny, little flat wart almost.
Very common.
Getting that surgically removed
really is a very little concern.
And I say that that way because typically
if you get a squabous cell
or a melanoma surgically removed,
you do increase the risk of it spreading.
So I'm not a big fan of that.
I think you should try to treat it alternatively first
if you possibly can if it's a squabous cell or a melanoma.
You can just make the cancer agree
that it could spread all over.
Especially if it's a melanoma
if you have metastatic melanoma
that becomes much more difficult to treat.
The basal cell, you could also treat
from a natural perspective too.
I've had seen lots of testimonials
of people that have treated basal cell
with essential oils or leaves of curcumin type cream
with high degree of success with basal cell.
With squabous cell, that can be a much more serious cancer.
You got to get into using right technology.
You got to get into working on nutrition
and using topical things.
Basal cell, typically it's just using something topical.
Melanoma is the most serious of those three.
My daughter-in-law was diagnosed
with cancer as tumor behind her.
I, she went to California to have surgery.
She came back to Idaho to have radiation
but the hospital won't do the radiation
because they say it is too dangerous any suggestions.
Well, I don't know if this is what type of cancer it is.
If it's a brain cancer behind the eye
in the frontal lobe of the brain,
but certainly sounds like a more serious type cancer
using as many alternative things
along with anything, standards of care
would be the best results for her.
Again, I'm a fan of any serious cancer.
I would never try to treat without using right technology.
That's frequency technology.
It greatly depends on what type of cancer it is.
Depending on what diet you're going to use.
Since we're talking about diet.
If it is a brain cancer behind the eye
and not an ocular melanoma or something like that,
then you have to think about more of a ketogenic type diet.
If it's an astrocytoma,
then there's different dietary parameters
that you want to look at
because astrocytomas tend to feed off of glutamine
quite frequently.
But definitely using anything that you can to do
to help boost the immune system.
If it is a brain cancer that makes it different
because that means it's across the blood brain barrier
and there's blood brain barrier issues
that you have to deal with too.
And that makes it harder for chemotherapy
to get in there as well.
If you're doing a chemotherapy protocol.
But definitely I would use a knife on any type
of serious cancer that if that's a new word
for a lot of you look up on our website.
Rive technology is using frequencies.
It's not a magic wand.
It doesn't make cancer just disappear
but it helps your immune system target the cancer.
And that's part of the problem when you are dealing with cancer.
And why is it my immune system killing this cancer?
And the answer is my immune system isn't killing the cancer
because cancer is your old cells
and your immune system isn't supposed to kill your old cells.
So you need to get the immune system to take a,
you know, another and another and another and other look
at this cancer to choose to destroy it.
And frequency technology could help with that.
And anything you do from a nutritional standpoint
is typically aimed around boosting the immune system
to be able to give that T cell response
to be able to kill the cancer.
What diet would you suggest for lung cancer patients?
So since this talk is really supposed to be
that not so radical cancer diet,
there are some cancers that are going to respond
to different diets on average.
So I made a comment about glioblastoma.
You know, on the average,
glioblastoma is gonna respond better to a ketogenic type diet.
Some of the other brain cancers
can respond better to a ketogenic type diet.
But in whole, your cancers can feed off of anything.
So cancers constantly just trying to fight a fuel source.
So take a step back again.
What is a cause of cancer?
Cause of cancer is anything that gets inside the cell
and damages the DNA of the cell.
So inside the cell, you is like literally New York City
taking place inside of each cell.
That's how much activities take you place in each
of your cells.
So if things get in there,
let's say toxins or chemicals or biotoxins,
that could disrupt the different organelle function
of the cell and cause health issues.
Could it affect the mitochondria
and could cause the T issues and such?
That's bad enough, but if it affects the nucleus
and damages the replication center of the nucleus,
so the cell goes into rapid replication,
that is cancer.
So by definition, anything that damages the nucleus
in a way that it's gonna cause the cell
to go into rapid replication,
replicating cells that are in rapid replication,
that is cancer, so that is a cause of cancer.
So your diet has to tie around,
no matter what kind of cancer you have,
your diet has to tie around partly about detoxification.
And then that cancer that is in rapid replication
needs a fuel source.
Now on a warburg described the fuel source
of many cancers, it's not all cancers,
but many cancers will use the end play of glycolysis.
If you remember high school biology,
glucose goes through a process of glycolysis
and ends with pyruvate.
And then converts to lactic acid
and hopefully converts to acetylcoids M-A
to go into the crem cycle to make a whole bunch of ATP.
That's how you make energy.
So a cancer cell is very dependent upon energy
more so than a healthy cell
because it's in rapid replication
so it's highly metabolic.
Any cell line that's more highly metabolic
needs more energy.
So it needs that fuel.
Now cancer cells can feed off of glycolysis
in the most efficient way
that a cell feeds off is through glycolysis
then through the crem cycle
where you make the most energy.
On a warburg discover that cancer cells
tend to feed off of just the end play of glycolysis
not going into the crem cycle
through a fermentation type process that's anaerobic
where it's actually burning lactic acid
which is kind of odd and kind of inefficient.
Now the thought process was that cancer cells
are just replicating quite quickly
so they need to get quick energy.
They can't wait for it to go through the crem cycle.
At least one of my theories is that people with cancer
can tend to have a genetic defect
on the gene that makes the enzyme that converts pyruvate
to acetylCoins IMA for it to go into the crem cycle.
Thereby cancer cells tend to feed off of an anaerobic
process through lactic acid.
It's a little technical, but that's the H9 run gene
that we look at with our cancer patients.
If that's the case, you're going to tend to feed
your cancer's going to tend to feed off of glycolysis
which means, so what does this mean in the bottom line?
If that's the case, then you want to be eliminating glucose
so a ketogenic type diet
where you're getting your glucose levels down
would be beneficial.
Now, when we talk about the not-so-radical cancer diet,
then when I talk about, we don't want to put our patients
on such a radical diet is that if you take a person
who's 70 years old has prostate cancer
and you put them on a ketogenic diet,
how long realistically is that person going to be motivated
to stay on a ketogenic diet?
It's difficult.
It's difficult for a 23-year-old to go on a ketogenic diet
and to get into ketosis
if that's what the purpose of a ketogenic diet is.
In reality, does a person need to do that?
Well, some researchers coming out that cancer patients
don't necessarily need to get into ketosis
to get the same benefit from reducing glucose.
So reducing your blood glucose really should be our goal
on those patients that the cancer is fed
through glycolysis, meaning through glucose,
through sugar, through carbohydrates.
So if that's the case with your cancer
and it can be with lung cancer,
but I'm gonna talk about in a couple of minutes
that cancers can feed off of other pathways too.
But if it's fed through glycolysis,
through glucose breakdown,
through the consumption of carbohydrates,
if a person can simply reduce their glucose levels
and that's something you can check at home.
You can buy a glucose computer at Target or something
and check your glucose levels, fasting preferably.
In the morning, you check your glucose levels,
it's 103, that's way too high for a cancer patient.
We wanna get our glucose levels down into the seventies.
That can be difficult because if you're 65 years old
and you've had abuse of your pancreas
and abuse of your glucose receptors on yourselves
for, you know, 60 years, it's not easy.
You can't just completely just eliminate all sugars
and get your glucose levels down.
So you gotta be patient with yourself.
So our comprehensive patients,
we give them a glucose computer
so as they can check their glucose on a regular basis,
typically they start daily
then maybe every three days, then every week
and they wanna get their glucose levels down into the eighties
and into the seventies, preferably.
If you do so, you can very effectively reduce
the cancer cell's ability to use glucose for energy.
Now understand, you're not trying to eliminate all glucose.
You need glucose in your body.
It's just elevated glucose where cancer has the availability
to snatch it up and use it.
Now I can't say that that is your fuel source
for lung cancer and I can't say that
well, you should just do that.
But certainly that's something you should consider.
Getting a glucose, everybody with cancer should consider
getting a glucose and you're measured your glucose
or trying to get your glucose down into the seventies.
Regardless of whether you're gonna also test for
or determine that the cancer is fed off of
glutamine or fed off of iodine or fed off
or something else and reduce those things,
that would be who anybody even if you don't have cancer,
try to get your glucose levels down.
I think there's plenty of studies that show
getting your glucose levels down and prolongs your life
to talk about heart disease being the number one cause
of death in the US still, is it tied to glucose levels?
Sure, yes, that's a tie to all, pretty much all
product disease and so something to look at.
ketogenic diet uses meat as it's made protein.
Meat could cause inflammation, which could cause cancer.
Do you still think that's a good diet?
Well, I would agree.
ketogenic diet does, you're using a lot of meat,
a lot of fat and a lot of ketogenic diets, a lot of dairy products.
And dairy products just kind of cross the border,
really pretty much it will know for cancer patients.
So can they have some butter?
Sure, should they be drinking milk?
Should they be even autocratic milk?
Even a non-pasturized organic milk?
No, is it still dairy products,
which dairy is meant to make small animals,
big animals in a hurry.
So it has growth factors in it.
And I don't think dairy should be something
that's in a regular diet for any cancer patient.
Meat, so meat has gotten a really bad ramp.
The last several years, a lot of people have gotten vegan
and vegetarian type diets.
Personally, I think that's the worst diet overall
for overall help.
That's just my opinion.
Now, some people do better on a vegan diet.
So I'm not saying that everybody fits into that category
because my philosophy is that nobody fits,
there isn't a diet for everybody.
So there's not a perfect diet for everybody.
My belief is that you have to look at how the way God created us.
I mean, there's people out there saying vegetables
are horrible for you.
Vegetables create chemicals in them to keep animals
from eating them.
And so that's a bunch of balali.
The truth is that God created food for us to eat
and anything within reason is right.
So I think vegetables are very good for us
and contain a lot of flavonoids
that are so important for cancer patients.
I think even berries and fruit can be very beneficial.
But I do think that we are created in season.
Now you're going to go ashore.
You can buy apples 365 days a year.
Is that right?
I mean, I don't know.
Just think about it.
Apples were supposed to be in season.
Yeah, you could preserve them in a road cell
there for a few months.
Do you really eat them for maybe half a year, maybe?
And then having that rotational diet,
I think is good for us.
You really do any studies on the microbiota
and such and the greater number of different types
and foods that you can eat the better it is.
And you look at the blue zones where people
are living into their hundreds, the diversity of their diet
is the number one common scenario
with most of these people in blue zones
is the dietary diversity.
I don't think meat is bad.
Does meat cause inflammation?
Yes, if.
So yes, if is the answer to that.
And if hinges around the most common health issue
in the world, which is a decrease hydrochloric acid production
of the stomach.
So your stomach cells make hydrochloric acid,
that's part of your pH balance.
So this whole idea about, I gotta
alkalize my system.
That's the problem with my cancer's growing
because cancer's growing in a acidic environment.
Okay, you know why?
You know how you actually alkalize your system?
You know what the worst thing you could possibly do
is eat something, eat baking soda or drink baking soda
or drink alcohol as alkalized water
because all you're doing there is alkalizing your stomach.
And you know how your body has,
you know your body alkalizes itself.
It's through the production of hydrochloric acid.
The byproduct is, is a, is a sodium bicarbonate
that's put into the blood as a buffer.
So that's how your body buffers the blood
and buffers the tissue is through the process
of creation of HCl.
But we've damaged our stomach through, you know,
dietary antibiotics, dietary pesticides, herbicides,
chemicals, food colorings, dyes,
all this garbage that we've eaten,
damages the vital cells of our stomach,
which are responsible for making hydrochloric acid
and buffering our body, alkalizing our tissues.
That's exactly what happens.
So when we have a decrease HCl in our stomach,
we set ourselves up for parasitic infections
because HCl is the primary, you know, forced response
to killing any pathogens that you consume.
So you're eating foods with bacteria and parasites.
If you have proper HCl, they're gonna be all dead.
HCl is gonna be primary response
to help you digest animal proteins.
So people have issues with animal proteins
and animal proteins meet causing inflammation.
The number one thing you wanna look at
is improper HCl production.
Most people and, and I'll tell you,
every cancer relationship you take heat,
hydrochloric acid, which each feel
and a digestive enzyme to help support the pancreas.
If you do that, you're gonna greatly reduce
the inflammation.
I'm more concerned about the inflammation
that's being produced in the gut,
which then is causing inflammation in the brain
and the lungs and the tissues everywhere else
by having antibodies to different foods
because many cancer patients like, okay,
you were perfectly healthy and had no problems at all
so you could diagnose breast cancer.
You had, you know, a cascade of health issues
that have taken place over your life
that maybe were never diagnosed
because maybe they were all some kind,
you didn't have a lot of symptoms.
And then you end up with a cancer diagnosis
well, pretty much guaranteed you
that you may have hidden autoimmune issues.
You definitely have had leaky gut issues,
definitely have, you know, possible Hpilora issues
and on and on and on.
So you gotta look at all those things
and try to uncover those things.
So yes, if a person is eating meat,
they're not used to eating meat
and they're having an inflammatory response,
you gotta look at why and treat the reason why.
Are you familiar with the RIFE machine F-165?
It is recommended, is it recommended efficient to use?
We have availability for this type.
Yes, and no, I spoke to somebody just recently
that has one of those.
I did look it up and, you know,
I've tested just about every RIFE machine on the market
and I've settled on two of them to be the most beneficial.
And that's the true RIFE for the GB 4000.
I've never tested this one.
So I don't know,
so I don't want to necessarily comment on that.
I will say that if you're treating cancer,
you have to be using a RIFE machine
that's using the light frequency.
So if you have the GB 4000
and you're just using the handheld things,
I don't think there's any benefit
through our cancer patients for that.
You have to get the MOPA and light the bulb.
The true RIFE comes only with the bulb,
doesn't have the handheld things.
You have to use light, this is my opinion.
You have to use light frequencies.
Light is a photon,
so you're carrying that wavelength on a photon
and that particle on that photon,
I think interacts with the cell differently
than just electrical energy.
So I think electrical energy is beneficial.
And when I looked at this machine,
I think really when you're using it with the panels
or just the handles,
it's really functioning as a PEMF pulse
to electromagnetic frequency machine
that you could actually dial in some frequencies,
which I think has great benefit.
But as far as cancer killing,
far stimulated your body to kill cancer cells,
I think it falls short.
But I think PEMF is extremely beneficial
for other things, it helps increase cell charge
and it helps stimulate an immune response.
It can bring overall help.
But as far as killing a pathogen
or killing a bacteria,
you're trying to get your body to kill cancer,
I think it falls short.
Do you recommend eating fermented vegetables
for breast cancer patients?
So for fermented vegetables,
so yes and no.
So there's newer studies that have come out
that are not actually necessarily new studies
that have shown that histamines can be an issue
and actually the studies I've referred to
were on breast cancer patients,
but I think it could be other cancer patients as well.
Histamines can be a major driver of breast cancer
and other cancers.
So you do have to be careful with that.
So fermented foods are fantastic
because they contain probiotics.
So you increase the benefit to the microbiota
of your gut and your tissues
and what could go wrong with that?
Well, the only thing that could go wrong with that
is fermented foods also have a lot of histamines
and if histamine is driving your cancer,
well, that could be a big, big, giant no no.
It has one of the main reasons why we look at genetics
because you can actually see a person's histamine pathways.
And if they have a lot of issues with their histamine pathways,
they really should be watching how many histamines
they consume.
So you have to be careful of that.
Now, if you have a cancer,
like how do I know this?
If I can't go and do a test like you're talking about,
well, if you have a cancer like breast cancer
that you can palpate and you know,
you can see a response to a dietary change.
If you're eating fermented foods
and you feel like your breast cancer isn't proving,
it's decreasing its size
and if you're seeing some improvement,
then maybe that's not your issue
and it's not being fed from histamines
and biobines continue that.
More often than that,
I see with breast cancer patients
if they eat a lot of histamines,
they'll notice an increase in inflammation
and not good inflammation.
So just be aware of that.
Second, they about fermented vegetables.
I think you're talking about just generally
fermented vegetable vegetables,
but there is the issue of fermented soy.
So soy, not good for breast cancer patients,
not good for any,
not good for anybody, really.
But soy is,
is contains estrogens.
It's estrogen disruptors in soy.
So it should not be consumed really by anybody
in any large forms whatsoever.
But certainly anybody that has a hormone
of different cancers should stay away from soy.
But here's the flip side of soy.
Research on a Japanist found that fermented soy,
like natto or miso,
actually has a beneficial response to breast cancer patients.
So understand,
hormone driven cancers,
the cancer is it being fed by estrogen.
Estrogen is just attaching to this certain receptor
on the cancer cell membrane.
It is blockied apoptosis.
That's, so the cancer is it didn't,
wasn't caused by bad estrogens,
nor is it being fed by estrogens,
if you have ER positive cancer.
But that these bad estrogens are attaching
to this apoptotic receptor on the cell membrane
and blocking cell depth.
Actually fermented soy has been found
to dislodge these bad estrogens from and progesterones
from those receptors.
So it can actually be highly beneficial.
There's actually a product on the market
that we use sometimes with these patients
called Highland 951.
It's a liquid eight ounce bottle
comes into the glass jar.
It's highly fermented soy
and you use it on ER positive cancer patients
to help dislodge that bad estrogen.
Because you could reduce your estrogens though
that nothing but you're still going to have estrogens
and the ideas you're trying to get it to dislodge that.
So using fermented soy can actually have benefits.
And I don't think you get to say
the long term histamines for that.
Oh, what about methionine restriction?
What is a good daily level of intake?
So methionine, glutamine, these are amino acids
that can be a fuel source for cancer.
So this is where you have to be careful.
So we do a test in our office.
We do a cheek swab test and I test with kinesiology
to find out what the fuel source is
and I will tell you it can change.
So cancer is constantly trying to find a fuel to feed it
because it's again highly metabolic.
It's sucking up energy.
It needs to make energy.
So it's sucking up anything you can make energy off of.
So methionine, amino acid, glutamine, even some other amino acids
can be a feeder of some cancers, not all cancers,
but some cancers.
So if your cancer is being fed off of those,
then you want to reduce the amount.
You need amino acids to make enzymes.
You need amino acids to live.
You're not eliminating all amino acids.
But what would be a good amount on people
that we found that amino acids are feeding their cancer?
We just typically eliminate it out of their diet
and we don't have them take it in any supplements.
Even across the board, I will say glutamate
is a worse culprit than the thiety.
And I suggest people just across the board
you should not be taking supplements with elglutamated it
or any high amount of elglutamated it.
Why would people take that?
Well, elglutamide is a supplement that's commonly
used to help heal leaky gut issues.
So any time cancer patients are going
to a functional doctor, a chiropractor,
a death scratch, or something like that,
and their thought is, well, we got to heal the gut first.
So let's get you on glutamated and some other things
to help heal the gut.
Well, that's a noble thing to think about.
You have to be careful that some things
that you would do with a heart patients
or some things that you do with a leaky gut patient
or some things you do to help heal other functional issues
in a person or not something you would do with a cancer patient.
So a cancer patient should never, and my book should never
be taking elglutamide because if it isn't
a current fuel source, if you're taking high amounts
of elglutamide, it can become a fuel source.
You're going to be getting glutamide, emethiety,
and aline in your foods.
You have to eat protein.
It's a very important for cancer patients to eat protein
because if you're not eating it up protein,
you cannot make the lymphocytes that you need,
the natural killer cells and the T cells,
the types of lymphocytes that you need to make
in order to kill cancer cells.
That's what you need to kill cancer cells.
And if you have a protein deficient diet,
you're not going to feel well.
You're not going to do well.
So that's the problem with going out of vegan diet is that.
I mean, vegans are much more prone to infections.
This is my opinion, and I don't want to insult anybody.
It's a vegetarian or vegan out there, so.
But if you have a serious disease like an infection
that you need in immune response or cancer,
that you need a highly functioning immune response,
going out of vegan diet is not the best thing to do.
That means that you really got to watch your amino acids
that you're going to find in supplement products.
What tests can I do to find out what the fuel source of my cancer
is I live in hungry?
There are 80 labs that you can do.
So there's no standard labs.
There's no functional labs that you can do
to find out the fuel source.
So we do kinesiology testing.
Some people might think, no, that's weird.
I don't want to do that.
That's fine.
And if you don't want to work with us to try to do kinesiology
testing, then that's understandable, too.
But then how do you know?
How do you know what your fuel source is
if there's no testing?
Well, you have to experiment that.
So you can experiment.
There is a metabolic assessment form out there.
You can probably Google it.
It's like 400 questions or it asks you what different questions
about your diet and your food and your fuel.
And then you put it through this assessment.
Then I think there's even a computerized one out there.
That's what Dr. Gonzalez used to use to find out
what a person's made probable fuel source is.
Nothing's going to be perfect.
And it can change, remember.
So that's what he used to use as a metabolic assessment form
and get a pretty good idea of what that person's cancer
fuel source is and then eliminate that out of their diet
or experimentation.
So if you have a cancer where you can visually see
or know whether it's progressing or not,
like a breast cancer where you have a lump
that you can palpate, it's much more difficult
than you go have a way to objectively measure it.
Certainly, if you have any cancer,
you could do tuber marker panels just to try
to get some objective measurement
short of having to do CT scans or MRIs or PET scans
on a regular basis, something less invasive.
But and then doing a diet and changing it up,
I think I talked with Dr. Carl fellow about this too,
it can be very beneficial to be changed.
If you don't know this, to be changing up your diet,
again, going back to what we talked about at the beginning
of this about having a diet that is changing with the seasons.
Ethically, we can get into a certain diet.
From Ireland and in Germany area
and we have certain foods that we like and from Minnesota,
we have kind of Norwegian-type palate.
I've had patients that are Italian
and are eating spaghetti sauce and tomatoes
with each meal that's high-elected
so that can cause all sorts of issues
if you're eating the same thing constantly.
So having a diet that's rotational
can be very beneficial.
But there isn't any blood tests
that you could run for that.
You said take digestive enzymes
and what was the second thing you should take, HCO.
So the most important thing that you could take,
we start dealing with, okay, I gotta help heal my digestion.
It starts from the top down.
You gotta be chewing your food really good.
You need to be breaking down your food.
You need to be, you know,
secreting talent from your salivary glands
to help you break down carbohydrates.
You need to be choosing right foods that you're not,
causing inflammation
and with cancer patients should try to, you know,
reduce dairy products right off the mat.
That should be a definite thing
that you can consider in other tests
that you could run to look at foods
or making sure you're not eating things
that are causing inflammation.
Running a Cyrex panel to look at gluten
and cross reactants to gluten and Cyrex array 10
to look at food sensitivities
where you have actually antibodies to different foods.
And every time you eat that food,
you're causing this inflammatory response in the gut.
It's very difficult.
Could that be related to your cancer directly?
Yes.
Could it be secondary and a comorbidity?
And that could be a major cause of why a person
is doing all the right things.
I'm doing all this nutritional things.
I'm taking all these supplements to help kill cancer.
I'm doing the right thing.
I'm doing all these things.
And I can't seem to get better.
Well, if you are not dealing with some of those comorbidities
and you're eating, let's say, gluten as an example
and every time you eat gluten,
let's say you have antibodies to glean and peptides,
every time you eat it,
you're causing this firestorm of inflammation of the gut.
Now your immune system is fighting the banal
at multiple fronts.
It's difficult to be able to kill cancer cells
when you're causing this hyperinflammatory response
in the gut, damaged in the gut,
and damaged to other tissues.
Do you have antibodies to other cell tissue systems?
Like your thyroid or arthritic tissues,
collagen fibers, et cetera.
So there are labs that can be beneficial to run
to find those things out to help heal that.
So when you're starting healing the digestive system,
you want to find that stuff out.
But for supplements, go HCl with your food
and digestive enzymes with each meal
is just standard that everybody shouldn't be doing
because just about everybody has a deficiency in HCl production
because we've been exposed to so many chemicals
in our diet that has damaged our pridele cells
of our stomach to make HCl.
So if you're supporting HCl production,
you're helping those pridele cells heal
and remember what do the pridele cells do
when they make HCl?
They make sodium bicarbonate to help
alkalize the rest of your tissue, which is important.
So taking HCl is very helpful, help skill pathogens,
helps break down your food
so that it takes stress off your gut.
But if you're eating foods that are inflammatory to your gut
that you have antibodies against in your intestinal tract,
you just create a firestorm.
You gotta deal with those things too
and don't consider those to be little things
and that cancer is a big thing.
Well, if you want to heal from the cancer,
you need to heal from those things.
Do we keep a therapy, do we radiation,
do we need a metotherapy?
That damages your gut epithelial cells too
and causes leaking out issues
and can cause that can be a major cause
of you creating antibodies to different foods
that are good, healthy foods.
So getting those tests done can be really helpful.
If you enjoyed our course, our stop fighting cancer course
or our autoimmune course, I have a bunch of courses
if you look at our website.
If you enjoyed one of those courses,
you're only 200 bucks to join a course.
It's just ridiculous for you not to do that.
Then you could actually order labs from the course.
The Syrex panel is the thing to do.
Actually, I'm going to give you,
everybody's on this call is going to get an option
to do a case review with me.
So a case review is that initial call with me.
So I don't care if you live in Hungary or California
or you live across the street,
it's still over the phone or over Zoom.
And we can talk about your condition
that I could give you some direction
that'll be on the streets.
So we're giving that, I think we're doing it for $99 or something
which is like 60% off.
And it's 30 minute call with me who will discuss
your condition and I'll give you a direction.
And hopefully, just listening to me here,
you'll know I'll be honest with you.
So, but I think everybody should do our course.
Just see you have the ability to run some labs
and to dig a little bit deeper in your body
to see what other things could be going on.
If people ignore colmoorbidities with cancer
because they think, well, I got cancer.
I got deal with this right now.
But you do need to deal with those things too.
Deal with other causes of inflammation.
Do you recommend taking Pactisol C daily
and also iodine both for prevention
and if someone has some type of cancer?
Pactisol C, I'd say yeah,
everybody could take Pactisol C
but there's probably a hundred supplements
that everybody could take.
So, I think too many supplements can be hard on your liver.
Now, Pactisol C is not something
that would be hard on your liver
because you're really detoxifying.
That's true, your liver pathways is not like.
Pactisol C can also be mild key later.
So, even so it isn't a cancer, Pactisol C could be good.
So, that would be something that could be on a yes list.
I had iodine, no.
So, you wanna learn a lot about iodine.
I have several videos of iodine.
I know there's some books on iodine there.
All pro iodine, every should be taking iodine.
I just totally get that.
And the reason is the research coming out
that has shown that iodine is an exogenous iodine.
I mean, we get iodine in our food.
And if you're taking exogenous iodine,
I mean, iodine is supplement four
which is typically potassium iodine.
But, you are greatly increasing your risk
for created antibodies to your thyroid.
I had to be sucked up by your thyroid.
It's gonna create an immune response to your thyroid.
That in fact, there was a study out of Japan that showed,
like they had 300 plus people with primary hypothyroidism.
That means they had low thyroid
but no antibodies to the thyroid.
TPO and antibodies were negative.
Thyroid globular antibodies were negative.
They started them on iodine
because that has kind of been the functional way.
Everybody should be taking iodine.
All women, you need to be taking iodine.
iodine deficiency is the problem with the thyroid.
That's just, that's just completely wrong information.
Sorry, that's totally disagree with it.
It was just completely wrong.
They put these women on iodine.
Every single one of them, not 60%,
100% of them within like so many months
developed antibodies to the thyroid.
So they're all ended up with Hashimoto's.
Now Hashimoto's versus primary hypothyroid
that's totally different from all the wax now.
Now you have antibodies to self tissue.
Every time you create an immune response,
you get a cold and you have an immune response.
You get cancer and you're taking a bunch of stuff
to kill your cancer.
You are also destroying your thyroid cells.
You don't want to have an autoimmune disease
and believe it or not, autoimmune diseases
are very common comorbidity with cancer patients.
Again, you didn't just have this perfectly healthy body
and now you get cancer.
There was other things going on.
So I am totally against taking iodine.
That in fact, every patient that I have,
I look at their shuffles and said I take them off iodine.
So what do you think about honey fermented garlic?
I am prostate cancer.
Honey fermented garlics like some of the videos
you might have seen on Instagram
or you're putting honey in garlic and that's great.
That's good.
That's good immune response.
Garlic is a great immune stimulator.
Very strong TH1 stimulator stimulates an immune response.
Garlic is good for a lot of things.
Garlic is good for H. Pylori,
which is a common comorbidity.
The most common comorbidity worldwide period.
The most common bacterial infection worldwide.
Common, one of the top five causes of heart disease
and the number one causes stomach cancer,
causes prostate cancer, et cetera.
So yes, I think that's great thing.
So the only thing I have to be careful
about taking garlic is if you're on a blood thinner
because garlic is the strongest nutrition of blood thinner.
And you don't want to be thinning your blood too much.
Matter of fact, I don't, I have had people
that have gotten lost in blood thinner by,
they're just substitute garlic.
My mom has metastatic colon cancer,
which has also gone into her liver,
been doing chemo else struggling with some neuropathy.
She may not want to do chemo much longer.
Any helpful information for combating the neuropathy
and any other potential will infects
from the chemo and keep you to her healthy.
Big questions, sorry, thank you.
So yeah, so are there things that you could do for neuropathy?
So most neuropathys are caused from diabetic neuropathy,
which has to do with elevated blood sugars,
damaging peripheral nerves.
So neuropathy, period, is damaged to a nerve.
So when you talk about chemotherapy-induced neuropathy,
you're talking about damage to peripheral nerves
because of the oxidizing effect of the chemotherapy,
chemotherapy is a poison, right?
And you're hoping that it kills the cancer
before it kills the patient.
But in the periphery, in your hands, in your feet,
you have slower circulation and slower rebound
on what was put into the tissues
through the limb system, getting it back out.
So you'll get more stasis fluid and more stasis
of the chemical in this case, chemotherapy.
You'll get stasis of the chemotherapy drug
in the periphery, simply because of blood flow.
That stasis of that chemical could damage the nerve.
So it damages the a favorite pathway of the nerve,
which is the sensory pathway from the receptor
back to the brain.
And when you get damage of that a favorite nerve,
you start to feel symptoms, tingling, pain, numbness.
That's what peripheral neuropathy is.
So it's damage of the nerve, the a favorite fibers,
because of something, in this case, chemotherapy.
Well, what do you do?
You have to detox the chemotherapy.
Well, how do you do that?
Well, there's a lot of ways that you have to do that.
So you have to support all the phases of detoxification,
and sorry, but I have a course on that.
I have a book on that.
You can download the book, the seven phases of detoxification.
Everybody has kids who should look at that.
So I think that's a free download.
So go on our website and look for that.
I have a whole course on it too,
but you can download the book.
It's a pretty easy read.
But looking at trying to pull that out of the body.
So some common sense type things.
You're looking at liver support.
You're looking at will the person do coffee animals
to help support the liver?
It helps stimulate parasympathetics.
How are their bowel movements?
Are they getting rid of stuff out of their gut?
Will they do some chelation therapy
to pull the stuff out of their body
and out of their tissues?
How's their limb system going?
Will they do sodas to help detox
through the skin?
So all those kind of things you want to help support
pulling the chemotherapy out of the body
because it just does have it in damages other cells,
obviously, like in this case.
So that's what you'd want to look at for something like this.
And then, you know, as far as helping a person
that doesn't want to do chemotherapy anymore,
hey, that's probably another one of the patients
that have failed, quote unquote, the medical system.
And now they're looking for some support
for an alternative perspective.
So yeah, you do things that will help stimulate the body
with the true rife, the sheen.
It also comes with the foot bath apparatus.
I had pro-wave and a lot of our patients are doing that
on a daily basis to pull junk out of their body
through their feet, too.
You said to avoid dairy, does that include raw goat milk?
Yep, it does.
So dairy is dairy.
Anything that's coming out of an utter is dairy.
Some people get that confused with,
well, I should need eggs then, right?
No, that's from a chicken.
So that's not theory.
What's your approach of salt consumption?
I read that a limited salt from the cancer diet
could restore electrolyte system
and the natrium potassium balance.
So I do know that Dr. Max Gerson
was really big into a limited salt.
So the Gerson protocol was, you're not eating any salt
and that was really important.
And his daughter carried that approach
on religiously everything that Max had said.
And she was, and so that, I think
it's still taught in the Gerson critics.
I might be wrong, but I think it's still taught
down there in Mexico now.
I think that has been pretty much debunked, though.
Remember, Max, a lot of things that were done
in the 40s and 50s and 20s and early 20th century
were correct.
And they were the right thing to do.
And Big Pharma changed it because they want you to be on drugs.
Coffee enemies would be an example.
Max was also big into coffee enemies.
So Maya, I think it's really helpful as been proven
to be beneficial, maybe for different reasons
that Max even knew, because it's mainly a parasympathetic stimulator.
He thought it was just a liver detoxifier,
but it works through, stimulating the vagal nerve.
That's really the benefit of a coffee animal.
But salt elimination has really been debunked,
I think, for cancer patients.
Now, I will say with blood pressure issues,
you can have a genetic profile that consumption of salt
greatly increases your blood pressure.
So those people should be off salt.
But not everybody has that genetic predisposition.
You could have high blood pressure
and you could have it under control
and you could eat salty pretzels
and it does nothing to your blood pressure.
So it's not 100% across the board for blood pressure either.
I don't think it's a factor, the same type of factor
that backs on.
Now, maybe true that we consume way too much salt,
and that might be an issue.
But I don't think that's how you get your electrolytes
back in the balance.
Matter of fact, you could look at a person's CDC
or a clinical metabolic panel and you can see where a person needs
has low sodium, low chloro, they need salt.
And more often than not that person's,
but I'm kind of a salt free diet for other reasons.
And they need to consume that.
But everybody's different, that's the thing.
You can't say it's the same for every single person,
most of the time.
If you have any general recommendations
for how much fruit someone can safely eat,
some people recommend only berries or green apples,
but, concept, they made so many different fruits.
Okay, so from a glucose perspective,
the fruits that have the least effect on your blood glucose
are the stone fruits, meaning the fruits that have a pit
like a club or a peach.
They can be very sweet,
but they have the least effect on your blood glucose.
They have the lowest glycemic index.
But that being said, the fruits that are more beneficial
for a cancer patient are probably the berries
because they have the most flavonoids.
So the more bio-flavonoids the fruit has,
the more beneficial it's gonna be in general
for your health.
Period, and certainly for a cancer patient as well,
bio-flavonoids are extremely beneficial to reduce
the slime inflammation layer around a cancer.
So, again, I tell you know, we have a lot of our patients
take, drink a shake, a green shake,
and I tell them to put frozen berries in there
with the green shake to taste.
So yeah, there's a limit to everything, right?
So you can say, oh, fruit's good for you.
So then you're gonna be a fruititarian.
You're gonna just eat gobs of fruit every day.
Anything can be out of balance.
So you have to have a balance per your weight, really.
And I don't have a figure of,
you can have X amount of cups per this many pounds of weight
or whatever it is.
But you have to use some kind of sense with that.
But I think using, you know, there's not as much
of a limit on stone fruits,
you're gonna knock on a spike your glucose level
and mix it up.
I don't think you should just limit it to green apples.
That was another Max Gerson thing
that I just don't agree with.
Again, that was when how many different kind of apples
that we had back in 1930.
So you gotta be looking where that information's coming from.
But eating honey fermented garlic
is it okay to eat the honey as well
or should it avoid the honey
because it contains such a high amount of sugar
that feeds the cancer?
Yeah, if any sugar is going to increase your glucose levels,
it's gonna maybe, maybe honey.
I'll be thinking, well, I'm not eating white sugar.
I'm just eating honey and I'm eating maple syrup.
Well, that might break down to glucose slower.
We didn't have a lower glycemic index.
So it's still gonna break down to glucose.
Again, monitor your glucose.
Go get a glucoseometer.
They're not expensive.
And just check your blood glucose levels.
Also, everybody, every person's body is different.
You could react differently to glucose.
I've had people that they were juicing carrot juice.
Well, that's high in glucose.
But I've had people juice carrot juice
check their blood glucose levels.
Does it do anything to their blood glucose levels?
I remember one girl, she drink like two ounces of carrot juice
and her blood glucose will go through the roof
and she did not have antibodies to carrots either
because that can be an issue
that you have antibodies to raw carrots.
That's causing this inflammatory response.
It was just really weird.
So I don't know the mechanism why that was for her.
But it's like, okay, you just can't have carriages.
So which was ashamed of her
because she really liked it too.
So but yeah, check your glucose when you eat that honey.
Yeah, if you just eat the garlic,
it's gonna be much better for you.
Any recommendations on how often you should do coffee
animals?
Well, my general recommendation is you do daily.
But it also depends on your health.
I'm in a state of remission for my kids or personally,
I don't do coffee animals, you know,
at all really anymore.
Unless I feel like it was about a,
what, six weeks ago, maybe two months ago,
I was having some bad gut problems again.
I thought, oh, here comes again.
And I'm done.
So I did coffee animals for a couple of days.
Clear it up and I don't know, maybe it was something I ate.
But it, but typically a person that's in the throes
of cancer, you do eat a coffee animals daily
are beneficial.
And again, the reason why you do a coffee animal
is not to clean out your gut.
No, that's a side benefit.
You do a coffee animal to stimulate
your parasympathetic nervous system.
And if that's a new word for you,
go to our website and look out parasympathetic
to search that in the search bar.
I have a video on helping you understand
the sympathetic versus parasympathetic nervous system
and some exercises you could download
that are just kind of silly little neurological exercise
that really help calm the sympathetic
and stimulate the parasympathetics.
Don't neglect that if you have cancer.
Don't neglect that if you have any serious disease.
You know, you might think, oh, I don't have a lot of anxiety
over my disease.
You could have a lot of hidden anxiety.
Or any anxiety in your body over a disorder
or for whatever reason, you have increased an anxiety.
You're going to have an increase in your sympathetic tone
and decrease in your parasympathetic tone.
Thereby, you're not going to be able
to listen to good immune response.
Your immune system is dependent on a parasympathetic reaction
and a good parasympathetic tone
as well as your detoxification pathways.
All your detoxification pathways are parasympathetically
orientated.
So if you're in a sympathetic overdrive,
you're not going to be detoxified.
I don't care how many, you know, pills,
you're taking supplements, you're taking it or whatever,
you're not going to be a good detoxifier
and you're going to be, you know, sorry, you didn't move that.
So coffee enemas can be a great parasympathetic stimulator.
I was looking at our college and par powder,
which says it has bovine, college and peptides
as an issue.
Also, there is also colostrum sold
in the, for the immune system,
seems these products are made of cows as well.
Yes.
So common question for our patients is can I take collagen?
That's one of the things I don't know
the amount of amino acids in the collagen.
I don't know how much immune growth type hormone stimulation
is in college.
I don't think it's that much.
I suggest our patients, but some of them are like,
oh, this collagen really helps me with this or that.
Can I keep taking this?
I tell them to pulse it.
So take it for a week off a week, something like that.
Take it a couple days a week.
Don't take it daily.
And that goes with a lot of your supplements.
So a lot of people get on something
and they stay on something forever.
It can be beneficial to pulse your supplements,
give in your body a break.
Maybe taking it five days a week
and then off on the weekend,
something that works for you.
For instance, we had a question
at our patient Zoom call yesterday
about dealing with parasites.
And I told him, I have a bottle of our pair of clear
here on my desk that I take.
But I would take it a couple of times a month.
So it's like, you know, I'm not,
I don't take a parasite clearing some of them in daily.
There's some things I try to take daily.
Like I take burberry pretty much daily
to help with H. Quailora, which is,
again, I'd say that's the number one bacteria in the world
and a major cause that he cancers
and the cause of stomach ulcers,
the cause of stomach cancer and a major cause
endothelial inflammation for your heart.
So cardiovascular disease.
So, and I take immune supplements and different things.
There's some things I take on a regular,
very regular basis with a daily basis.
But some things this can be good to pause.
That I would say with college and that would be one of them.
How about cruciferous vegetables?
So cruciferous vegetables.
I will all in favor of basically all vegetables.
The only vegetable for a cancer patient
that you want to limit would be kale.
That seems odd because kale is supposed to be really good for you.
And the reason why it's good for you is because kale
has the greatest amount of nitric oxide in it.
Like four times more than spinach.
So kale is really good for your heart.
But you don't want high amounts of nitric oxide for cancer.
So what does that do?
So epithelial nitric oxide synthase
stimulates a pathway called your vascular endothelial growth
factor pathway.
So that's short to veg F.
You may have heard of that.
Your veg F pathway is how you develop new vessels.
That's really important for heart.
So you want to stimulate veg F pathways for your heart.
So nitric oxide is a great thing to take for your heart.
It could decrease your blood vessels.
It could help build more blood,
decrease the inflammation in your blood vessels,
decrease your blood pressure,
and build more blood vessels in your heart.
But you do not want to do that with a cancer.
It's kind of a point with leukemia.
But when you have a hard cancer or solid cancer
like lymphoma or breast cancer or prostate cancer
or colon cancer, you don't want, this is where.
Some things that are good for,
from a functional medicine perspective that are good for you,
everybody should be taking this or everybody should be taking this.
Not for cancer.
So be aware of that.
Don't take glutamine for cancer.
Oh, should everybody be taking that?
Because it'll help heal, leak you gut.
First of all, you've got to fix the reason
why you have a deal with all that.
You don't just take supplements for it.
Secondly, for cancer patients,
you don't want to be doing that because glutamine and methionate
and such can be eaters of cancer.
And then with nitric oxide and cruciferous vegetables,
the only thing you really want to be watching
is you don't take exogenous nitrous oxide.
I mean, by supplement to nitric oxide or things
that will stimulate nitric oxide production in your body
from a supplement perspective.
And from a dietary perspective, it's really care.
So stay away from care.
You get some, but you still need a kale shake.
Dieter suggestions for someone undergoing finishing
pelvic radiation and endometrial cancer.
So I already talked about dietary things with cancer.
Everybody's a little bit different with that
and some general things that everybody should watch
as far as radiation goes.
How do I help detox the radiation that I had to have
with my cancer?
Let's talk a little about that.
With our patients, we use hoeopathics to help with radiation,
because it tends to work fairly well.
The dangers, positives and negatives of radiation therapy,
positive is it's going to kill cancer.
It's iodizing, it's going to kill cancer directly
and it's going to kill cancer quickly.
Meaning, if I have, if I have a stasis to my bones,
I have cancer that has metastasized to the bone
and I have really bad bone pain,
the danger to that is it's almost always going to be
a lytic type cancer.
Now, the stasis to the bone, it's going to be
eat away the bone and cause bode destruction,
which the danger to that is that you could easily end up
with what's called pathological fracture of the bone.
So the bone just crushes and that brings a whole bunch
of problems, right?
So that can bring a lot of pain too.
So even if there isn't a pathological fracture,
you can have a lot of pain for the lytic lesion
cobbling up your bone.
That's where I think radiation can work real well.
It can really shine to that because you could hit it
many times, there's a few times
and you could just stop the destruction, you could kill it.
We've had patients that had severe, severe bone pain
that was just crippling,
that they were just dogmatically set against doing radiation.
Their oncologist was trying to encourage them to do it
and they just did not want to do it.
And I basically had to try to talk of me into doing it
and listening to their oncologists
because you could get dramatic changes in your symptoms
like literally overnight.
And I can't tell you how many patients that did it
and literally a pain of God within four or five sessions
and they could stop.
And many times the radiologist,
the radiologist was very sensitive to that patient.
No, they didn't want to do it in the first place
and though they might have scheduled 10 treatments,
they stocked after three or four that had great results.
So, but the negative of radiation,
especially when you do kind of blanket radiation
over soft tissue is if you could actually create cancer
because what is radiation?
Radiation damages cells.
I and I see that's what it's doing to the cancer.
You're hoping that you're gonna be able to kill the cancer
before you actually cause cancer at other cells
and that's the danger of radiating these blanket areas
like doing the whole radiating, the prostate bed
or had to love back to me and I radiate the breast.
You can end up with the melanoma or sarcoma
or other cancer lymphoma because of the radiation.
So you do want to try to pull that out of your body.
We use some different radiation homeopaths to help do that.
But certainly doing everything you possibly can
to simulate your detoxification pathways
that I speak to in the seven phases of detox,
information, book and course, would be who you as well.
Okay, so, someone recommended taking
Ivermectin once daily for three weeks
and also the bed is all 100 grams twice daily
for up to six months for cancer, any comments
would it be hard on your liver to handle?
Can you make too many comments on medications
or a little medical legal standpoint?
But no, I don't think these drugs are hard on your liver.
Yeah, if a person has compromised
and they're seriously compromised health
and they're aged and they're not doing well,
I would maybe if you're gonna do this approach
regardless of where you're supposed to be doing
that comprehensive metabolic panel on a regular basis
on a CVC on a regular basis, even monthly,
to make sure you're keeping it up on liver enzymes
and making sure there's not an inflammatory response
in the liver.
But from a typical standpoint, these drugs are fairly safe.
And I think there's a lot of evidence
that these are safe, there's evidence
that these can be very beneficial for cancer.
So I don't see any harm in giving those a try,
but I take any compassionate medical doctor
who would be equal support of that.
If broccoli causes me bloating,
can this still be beneficial in my cancer diet?
I'd say no, so if some foods are causing you
bloating same with beans, then you have to look at,
do I have a sensitivity to that food?
Do I have antibodies against that food?
You can have antibodies against good things
that are good for you.
So doing a Cyrex panel can be beneficial
to find out what that is.
But just from a food elimination diet,
just historically, I can't eat broccoli.
I tend to have a sensitivity to it.
You could just have, you have, you're hard to digest.
Again, broccoli and beans and things,
they can be just difficult to digest.
So why are they difficult to digest?
Because most people have a deficiency
in HCL and digestive enzymes.
So try that, try taking some HCL and digestive enzymes
when you eat that, try cooking it.
Okay, so there's all this thing about raw.
Everybody should be eating raw.
That's the whole thing because it has enzymes in it.
If you cook it, you destroy the enzymes.
Okay, stop listening to some of this stuff like this.
It's a lot more difficult to digest raw vegetables
than it is to digest cooked vegetables.
There's a diet that we put a lot of autoimmune patients
that are called the gaps diet.
That's where you're basically starting raw
and then you move to eating soup,
which is highly cooked vegetables.
Make soups, oh, you're losing all the nutrients.
You're losing it in the broth, eat the broth then.
And you're not just eating all these vegetables
just to get the nutrients.
I'll tell you right now, if you don't have a healthy gut
and you're eating raw, even juicing.
Oh, juicing is great because you're pre-digesting it.
That's great.
You still have to absorb it.
You have to break it down into small pieces
that you can see.
You have to break it out in a microscopic pieces
that you can get across the gut membrane.
And that can be difficult for people,
especially as we age.
And so raw diets can be hard on your gut.
So making things in a soup type form can be beneficial.
If you're still getting some bloating of things,
you do not examine other things that could be going on
with your gut, start with digestion, start with HCL
and digestive enzymes.
When taking one to two doses of methylene blue
five days a week, be beneficial.
I am also using red light therapy.
Well, but methylene blue can be beneficial
for some things.
I'm not a huge fan of it for cancer patients.
We've tested it as a tested well.
Red light therapy can be good for some things too.
That's not going to be a cancer killer,
but I don't think there's any involved doing it
for other beneficial benefits with the skin too.
Someone recommended dandelion root and leaves
would make you the tea of this be good.
Absolutely.
Dandelion root is really good for your liver.
So dandelion root, dandelion tea is really a liver
it helps with phase one phase two pathways in your liver.
Something we recommend quite frequently.
Okay, so I do again to contact our office
if you want to have a case review with me,
it's normally $225, but we're going to,
anybody that's on this call or listed in this call
is going to be $99, and we're going to have a limited time
for that, I don't know what that is,
but you could get the discount of case review
if you want to talk to me.
It's to fill out the educational form on our site,
which gives me kind of your history.
If you can send me your labs and all that kind of stuff
and listed your supplements,
things that could be helpful for the call
and could give me more information
and more things that we can discuss.
Again, it's not a medical visit,
but it's a way that we need to know each other.
I can give you some direction,
hopefully anything gets a benefit off of that.
That's if you want to get started anyway,
if you just want to talk to me personally about your problems
or your family problems, whether you have cancer or not,
that could be beneficial.
Also, please check out our courses.
So some people go, I don't have anybody to start
with another doctor.
Do our courses, I add to our courses constantly.
Our stop fighting cancer course
is probably most appropriate for a cancer patient,
even has portal calls and stuff in there.
And I put videos on there and I think it's valuable.
It kind of goes through my book
in a video type format in more detail.
It's easier to watch.
You can jump in and out anytime you want and study it.
My autoimmune course, if you go to have cancer,
you have people with other cool morbidities,
that's probably my best course.
It's the latest one I did.
And those are cheap.
So jump on those two.
So we will get an email out to everybody,
hopefully, about the discounted case review
but call away office if you need to instead of a time.
Fasted said, hopefully we'll get the recording sent out
tomorrow to everybody.
I hope this was beneficial.
You know, I don't know everything,
but I try to be honest with everybody.
And I learned just as much from you guys as you do for me.
So I know that I'm praying for all of you
and not as I've played everything for you
and just kind of trust you and get all the things.
So thanks for being on and we'll do this again soon.
All right, bye-bye.